how many conventions have you been
in like you're like all together you
reckon because you probably out of
everyone i know you've probably been to
the most conventions yeah
yeah i we we were it was it's so
fun meeting and connecting with people
right that i was just so addicted to
just
being able to like see
the people that were just being so
[ __ ] cool online because you just
have that like natural light high energy
yeah i've noticed like when i when i saw
you in like when i saw you in hawaii at
your like signing i was like it was like
really [ __ ] professional because you
were just like you gave so much
attention and just like enthusiasm to
every single person regardless of like
how shy or not they were yeah and then
you know every now and then you'll get
those like weirdos because obviously
you're going to when you're in that
field right but like you just handled it
like a [ __ ] pro
yeah i'm i'm i'm jealous i i wish i
could be as high in gsu because i saw
one of your signings in ax and i
remember thinking like i saw you like
gave everyone a hug you were just like
so friendly with everyone i'm like [ __ ]
man i just give it i just give people a
handshake and a picture and then i just
like that
though you know like i think i think my
my appreciation
is that's just how i
i want them to know how appreciative i
am of everything that they've given to
me i have
still probably imposter syndrome
hardcore because i feel like i was just
at the right place at the right time and
the right thing you know and so anybody
who
who wasn't there true but like i don't
know i feel like i'm i'm very of the
like put out into the world what you
want to like kind of receive
and so
that but then also just appreciating
just about you but i do see you as
someone who is also like very
hypocritical of themselves right like
yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean i guess i
guess most people in that field are like
i would say most cosplayers are right i
think i watched your the documentary on
rooster teeth you did yeah i watched it
i had to sign up to a [ __ ] rooster
teeth membership
i cancelled i cancelled it right after i
was good
i'm sorry we should see there was
nothing else i wanted to watch i think i
was just curious i was like what could
it be like it's a documentary i'm like
well what's going on
yeah it was really good i wish it was
longer i wasn't so sure oh because it's
just like a little you're like that's me
this time
i got dick dug into my couch i was ready
and i'm like 30 minutes we're right with
credits yeah well just little guys
it was really good yeah i liked how a
lot of the focus was on like yeah how it
must it's hard dealing with all of the
the eyes on you yeah and all the
expectations and yeah people talking
[ __ ] yeah
because again like you didn't have that
gradual build that a lot of cosplayers
and just like people on the internet
have like it was literally just zero to
a hundred well i think even then it's
like now even if you are big it's like
it's such a big thing now where a lot of
people there are there are so many
cosplays over like a million followers
right yeah 100 percent right i think
when you started it was very much not
that it was yeah there was there was a
very small pocket of us that kind of
like grew yeah i feel like now
accessibility to
uh social media and just being able to
blow up on social media is so common and
other ways of monetizing it right like
there's so many ways to make money from
cosplay so much and it's it's it's like
really great and really
really kind of i couldn't imagine doing
what i do now in this space from scratch
today right right you used to be like a
ruthless business person to make it work
yeah the method is just completely
different you have to be on that like
sigma grind set
like are you not doing that with your
phone [ __ ] just like no i'm i'm chilling
right now i'm full like like yeah but
like i'm just two weeks making a cosplay
i don't know yeah but that's that's for
me that's because that's your sigma
grind set yeah
okay
the fact that you're waking up every day
for like two weeks just to grind out
this costume i'm like it's [ __ ] low
you know it's just because i want to do
it yeah because i don't know it's not
like a like
the the the sigma grind set for me is um
i don't know if i can say this but
look at that yeah only fans yeah this is
the pg-13 podcast that's true we were
talking about [ __ ] pizza earlier yeah
um
because it was a great idea i wasn't
sure you were like
[ __ ] pizza
i wasn't sure where you were mainly like
being i guess
what your presence was i wasn't sure
cause i know you have youtube you have a
twitter you i think you have patreon as
well i did for a while
yeah cause i didn't know like i just
know you as the person online i remember
because you're like yeah because you're
like i i know they're no they know we're
on youtube right know that's our thing
but i didn't know like what you're where
you were i remember your thank you yeah
i i remember when you [ __ ] upload
videos which is yeah yeah yeah yeah oh i
did so i did mail mondays for a really
long time and they were like mail
mondays from like way back so like man
that was like the wild west back then
you could do whatever back then i was
like like hannah minks was my goddess
you remember oh yeah yeah
wherever you are oh my gosh um so i i
had to actually have to private on my
videos because a lot of my videos were
not
would send me stuff in the mail and i
would just put it on right there yeah
15-inch dragon dildo oh man never got
one of those that'd be sick
they're expensive like wait how much are
they a few hundred bucks
yeah what kind of what kind of thing i
don't know we'll talk about off screen
we're still waiting for a sponsor
sponsor them
uh what the [ __ ]
okay i remember what i was gonna ask now
oh yeah how did the [ __ ] documentary
come around like what was that all about
that happened so i so i did stuff with
like rooster teeth because like a whole
bunch of my friends were rooster teeth
and everything so like barb and all them
and and then they were just kind of like
we kind of want to just do a documentary
and we want to do like think because
you're like you're a friend of rooster
teeth yeah we love working with you yeah
let's just
do what who's jessica what was you what
was your initial reaction to that i was
like
yeah i can imagine you'd be like
not me i'm so like just me it was it was
really weird though because like
people were
people were kind of like like the hate
online was kind of like oh whatever
she's a [ __ ] right before the before
the thing and then after the documentary
everyone was like oh my god i see her
now
and i was like wait why did they hate
you before just cause like you know
because she because she kind of yeah
because she kind of as well but like it
was also the fact that you just kind of
came out of nowhere and just overtook
the scene yeah right so yeah so
immediately all the eyes were on you
because it's like who is this jessica
jig and why is she everywhere yeah kind
of thing so like naturally with any
person it doesn't matter if they're an
absolute [ __ ] or the nicest person
ever yeah they're gonna get that initial
this was also before there was like this
real awesome like yeah sex workers like
everything so it was like way back when
like if you dressed like
yourself online then you were an
absolute cooler you know yeah so when
when everyone kind of like saw the
documentary and everything they were
like oh she actually makes her costumes
oh
oh wait oh she got bullied oh
oh she's a human being she's a human
being a human being yeah it was it was
kind of weird because i was
not prepared for people to be okay with
me
that was an incredibly weird sensation
did you get a lot of people reaching out
being like hey long time no tour not not
in like a no in like a in like a
connecting human way right
really really interesting and i did not
know how to prepare and that was
probably more tough than dealing with
like people being dicks online no it was
people being nice
you're like don't don't don't do that i
know you're lying don't give me hope
don't do they almost had us at the first
time yeah yeah
if someone's nice to you and they expect
a response it's way harder to like i
feel like formulate that response or
give them what you think they want or
try and think of just anything then yeah
if they're a dick you're like oh [ __ ]
off yeah it's
that's a really good way to explain it
yeah yeah cause then you kind of go like
i'm not like what you're trying to say
yeah yeah that's easy oh yeah i can just
miss that or whatever but then if
someone's like oh you you i really love
what you do i'm like
you have so many expectations oh my god
i hope i don't [ __ ] let you down oh
my god you sweet angel why am i going to
look
don't look up to me oh
my god it's like i don't know if it's
growing up in england but every try
every time i try to like genuinely share
gratitude i always sound sarcastic yeah
yeah
like i'm like oh thank you so much i'm
like am i sounding sarcastic now i have
to clarify i'm not being sarcastic
yeah yeah yeah yeah before i say
anything nice yeah yeah that's the curse
of the british it is it is everything we
say sounds like either sarcastic or
self-deprecating like it's being
important being like positive is just
like a [ __ ] anomaly to us well to the
american accent positivity i think yeah
do you think so oh yeah definitely yeah
like oh my god
it's so it's so it's so easy to sound
hyper positive with an american accent
yeah yeah yeah well if you have a
british or an australian accent it's
really hard but
wonderful thank you for having me if i
said that to you you'd think like wow
what did i do wrong no i wouldn't i'd be
like
i'm like say it again like on the flip
side on the flip side oh my god
on the flip side if you see like a
negative american or something or like
someone who is an an american being
angry it just hits that much harder you
know oh right
that's why you guys can't say the c word
without it sounding like a really
[ __ ] dirty word yeah
yeah i mean you can well you can do the
australian accent you can do the
australian ones but like but when an
american says it's like oh
oh i understand i understand why you
call it jesus christ
oh that's
[Music]
yeah
i've completely forgotten what we were
talking about before the documentary
documentary yeah like so
were they just like hey we're gonna
[ __ ] follow you around for like a few
weeks yeah so they came over and they
were like okay what's the plan i was
like um i was like okay well i'm getting
ready for blizzcon and i'm going to make
this costume for you yeah remember this
yeah he's going to make a loon for
blizzcon and i was i was genuinely in
the zone and it was going to happen and
i was going to work on it and it didn't
completely fell through right and so i
was like [ __ ] so then i changed gears to
alextraza and so then i was able to [ __ ]
alex grass out in like two weeks because
i don't know i don't know like powerball
you know so
that makes it sound so much more like
this
lines of code
just started like smoking weed in like
2018.
every new everyone used to think that i
was like on serious drugs never done it
oh man
that's why as much as the hawaii
experience with jess was amazing it was
also the most draining experience
hanging out with jessica for more than
like three days in a row i'm just like
the film crew just like yeah yeah
i'm sorry i was like okay i now no i am
yeah you suck the energy out of me i'm
like i want to hang out but [ __ ] dude
i'm so tired were they were they just
following you like throughout every day
they were at your house
yeah so what they did is they they came
over and then we did like they like
drove around they're like okay would you
like to do some sort of like like we'll
go with you to get some materials and
then we can like talk about like uh like
your growing up experience and
everything new zealand stuff and then we
like did the whole costume process and
everything and then they came to
blizzcon and they filmed that stuff too
yeah
that must be weird was it right to have
your own documentary oh it's so weird
how would you because like how would you
reckon how would you react if someone
just came up to you and was like we want
to make a dog country about you i mean
my my biggest concern would be like
what's the angle like what are you what
are you trying to portray me as like is
it like a sympathetic thing of like woe
is me or is it like what a [ __ ]
badass sigma male grind set like he's
just like look at this look at this
monkey what would i be [ __ ] doing
sit in my room all day like i don't
[ __ ] do anything like i feel like i'd
be so boring i feel like i've got such a
crazy like obsession with like like
because i i got really into watching
streamers over the pandemic yeah and so
um i i would watch that i would watch
that because i want to know what like a
streamer's mentality is like when you're
when you're doing that like xqc grind
you know like eight hours a day they are
a different breed of human yeah
and just go
some days you're just like [ __ ] i do not
want to press go live
feel like you're [ __ ] down a bunch of
coffee like
let's go it doesn't feel good when you
start though right like
when you see all the [ __ ] the chat
going crazy that shit's more serotonin
than anything i don't know why that's
something like about that all the emotes
he's gone too deep bro
he's a troll
so [ __ ] much yeah you're a real
streamer you can do like 12 14 hour
streams no problem that's like
i'd even need to take a break he says
that would like that would just yeah no
that's true i've done that like back to
back a few days ago
it's i don't know when you find the
right thing to stream it just feels so
like
fluid so nice
yeah but that was like three days of
where i was like addicted like i
couldn't put it down and i was just like
this is so fun it was such good content
yes yeah that's true like i've like i've
i've been streaming more often recently
and i've been doing like before i used
to like struggle to do two hour streams
and now do like sometimes four to five
hour streams but like
sometimes there are some streams that
just drain your [ __ ] oh yeah yeah
and i remember one time i was like
streaming like i think i was like going
for like an anime chart or something and
i was only like about halfway through
and i was like [ __ ] knackered so i
said i said i was like going to get like
a drink or coffee or something and then
i just left and then i just i just sat
down and i was like [ __ ]
what if i just don't come back
i think i just didn't come back for like
five minutes i lost like a thousand
viewers i was looking at my analytics i
was like why did i drop like a thousand
viewers and i was like oh yeah cause i
just i just left and i'd like i just
left and didn't say i was going to come
back
with this now
that's so funny but yeah i [ __ ]
needed that because it was just like so
[ __ ] draining yeah like i admire like
anybody who is just on a consistent
youtube schedule or like streaming
schedule like you guys just be like on
that on that grind is just it's
it's
well it's it's like what you said it's
just an addiction you just love it yeah
i just like it like i definitely
wouldn't be able to do what you do yeah
30 30 conventions i'd miss my home so
much